[Music]
[Music]
amethyst is an existing character
in dc we always wanted to do this so
when dc started doing their young
readers line
we we first were like
who do you want to do we were like
wonder woman and amethyst and they said
okay we were like what are you kidding
me that's amazing when i was
uh thinking of the concept for like how
it looked the art i just thought about
all the stuff i enjoyed as a kid and
like when i loved
like i used to read all the time i just
loved all the bright colors and all like
the fun expressions i really wanted to
make sure that i like
made amethyst
and general just feel so fun like just
make it feel like just something that
kids would enjoy actually
somewhere they want to be you know and
amethyst is like a friend you want to
meet like you know what i mean like just
make it super like inviting and warm for
everybody
well i think anytime we're writing
fantasy we like to have the the personal
journey and then the outward journey
balance each other and reflect each
other so anytime we're writing like
here's a big battle scene
she's physically defeating these gem
bugs uh what does this mean to her
personally you know how is she feeling
about this you always are keeping that
in that tension in balance and it's
super useful too to have a character
you know we we have her friend autumn in
there who is
just human she's just
regular and so she's kind of our eyes as
a reader you know looking at this
amazingness from the point of view of
someone who's like what is this yeah
i was just getting to see it for the
first time getting exposed to it for the
first time just like the reader is
i tried to like try to
make that obvious because like sometimes
from the pages autumn isn't like saying
anything she's just like looking around
amethyst was like worried like i need to
do this and you know everybody else is
like trying to do stuff
i'm here and i'm having a great time
the art the kids will love the art the
most yes
oh that's so nice i disagree i think
they're gonna well i guess it's like a
package thing i think our teamwork with
the characters is really what's gonna
push it because i think the friendship
between the kids are so great like you
know amethyst and autumn their
relationship is just adorable i love
them they're super supportive for each
other i think the kids are gonna
hopefully be able to like relate to that
level of friendship just be like this is
my buddy like we do everything together
like they're awesome i'm awesome we're
just going to have a good time and
whoever is around they could have a good
time as a writer i always keep in mind a
story is the relationships between the
characters there is no story without
that that's what every story revolves
around and i think in this one that the
friendship trio is
i think that's going to be your i think
you're right that's going to be their
favorite part and then maybe also the
magical elements the creatures and
possibly the chocolate fountain yeah
well then the whole wish fulfillment
stuff like that's what i like or like
you know the becoming something amazing
yeah
i really liked that when i was a kid too
that the whole you know it's the billy
batson shazam kind of thing where you're
a kid and then suddenly you are special
[Music]
i think the best part about drawing gym
world is that i could like it felt
unique so when it came to like me
actually trying to figure out like what
did the trees like wasn't the grass look
like what do the people look like it was
like super is it like super fun to just
imagine all the whimsical fantastical
stuff in there like all the different
weird animals and how how the buildings
look like it was just so fun to just
back and just sit on my desk like how
how funky can i make this like how how
extreme can i go it just let me like
really flex out my imagination muscles
and like challenge myself with art
well you know in in some ways um you
mean she in my mind at least she was
never really that obscure yeah and
shannon grew up doing fairy tales right
and reading a lot of fantasy novels so
this felt like a perfect kind of merging
for us and which is why we originally
wanted to do this character about almost
20 years ago
because it's like it is a dc superhero
who's in a fantasy universe
um you get the kind of the best of both
worlds we did a couple of changes we
made from the original amethyst she
doesn't age when she enters gem world
you know originally she was like a 12
year old and then she was like 20 when
she comes to the gym world we just had
her remain her same age but just gem
worldified right in the scripture were
like
go go big big hair big 80s yeah i was
like watch watch the ball scene in
labyrinth
that's what we want
so we wanted to be true to the fantasy
roots as well as the superhero roots
with as well as like a you know a modern
kid and what their view of the whole
world would be and mix all those three
things together
[Music]
you